today we have a very special guest a
friend of the briefing room uh returning
today you all know national economic
council director brian diese ryan is
joining us to give some brief comments
and answer some questions on the
president's actions today to respond to
putin's price hike by increasing the
supply of oil and achieving lasting
american energy independence so i'm
going to turn it over to brian who's
going to make some comments and then
we'll take some of your questions
thank you kate
just want to say thank you kate uh
so
um i just wanted to give a little bit of
additional background on
a couple of the elements of what the
president announced today and then happy
to take your questions uh the first uh
is on the release of the
strategic petroleum reserve
as you all
just heard from the president he today
authorized
the largest release from the strategic
petroleum reserve in american history
uh one million barrels a day for uh six
months
and i just want to give you a little bit
of context first uh the strategic ritual
reserve itself uh is our national asset
to deal with emergency supply
disruptions
in energy markets uh there's currently
568 million barrels
in the reserve which is actually in four
locations across
southern louisiana and texas and the
president authorized this reserve under
his
extraordinary emergency powers
associated with supply disruptions
which have we we have seen in the market
are
associated with
putin's
unjustified actions and the reaction
from the united states and allies in the
world in no longer
purchasing russian
oil
the scale of the release is
unprecedented so a million uh barrels a
day uh and uh the duration is also
unprecedented uh six months
the duration is was really designed and
calibrated to
operate as a bridge a medium-term bridge
to the period where we anticipate and
expect u.s production to come back
online
the most estimates based on commit
commitments by companies are that we
will see an additional million barrels a
day from u.s industry by about the end
of the third quarter of this year so
this the time period operates as a
bridge until then
and the amount a million barrels today
is is unprecedented but feasible based
on the technical capabilities of uh the
strategic petroleum reserve itself
um we also know there is significant
demand in the market we are operating in
a supply constrained market that is the
core challenge that is addressed that
has uh driven prices up uh but we saw
for example the last uh um
uh the last sale that the strategic
petrol reserve conducted was
oversubscribed uh by about two and a
half times uh so there is demand out
there in the market
um the last thing that i would say is
that
a very important element of the
president's announcement today was that
the president authorized the sale
but also the commitment to repurchase
oil
and that will happen in coming years
at a lower price
and that's important for
two reasons one is yeah it provides that
bridge to
during this period of extraordinary
supply constraint
but it also provides stability to the
market in the future that there will be
a buyer
to purchase oil at a lower price and it
also allows us to actually
maintain and increase the resilience of
the strategic petroleum reserve over the
long term we will be
refilling uh the reserve and if we're
buying at a lower price we'll actually
be in a position to refill at a more
barrels ultimately so uh the current uh
568 million barrels will come down but
then we'll go back up and that's how the
reserve functions um secondly just
briefly i wanted to touch on the
presidential directive that the
president signed today
authorizing the defense production act
for usage for
the critical materials that go into
large capacity batteries so
the president took this action under
title 3 of the defense production act
which
provides for um prioritizing and
subsidizing the production domestically
of key inputs that are critical to the
national defense so the secretary of
defense has undertaken a study
and identified that large capacity
batteries are critical to the national
defense and the components that go into
them
including
lithium
and nickel cobalt graphite manganese my
guess is that's the first time in the
white house briefing room someone has
said manganese
these are critical minerals and we are
currently
vulnerable to unreliable supply chains
which affects our national security it
also affects our economic security as
well so taking uh
by taking this action the president is
authorizing uh the government to use the
dpa authorities to build domestic
production capability in these key
materials and this is going to be a key
driver for building a domestically
resilient supply chain to build large
capacity batteries those are the
batteries that go into electric vehicles
but also used for storage
in other applications and also to
accelerate
what the president talked about today of
how we move to true energy independence
by reducing our dependence on oil
the amount of oil that we consume
and reducing our dependence on fossil
fuels
so
those are uh those are two we uh the
president touched on other issues as
well i'm happy to take questions all
about but i wanted to put a little bit
more context on those too
great thank you two questions brian
thank you for being here
um one to the figure one million barrels
per day to the skepticism that that
sounds unrealistic
why should americans have confidence
that you're going to be able to meet
that benchmark on a daily basis
and when can americans expect to
actually see the price of gas
so on the first one the department of
energy strategic petroleum reserve have
now committed uh per the president's
direction to release a million barrels a
day into the market uh number one we
have the full operational capacity to do
that as i mentioned there are actually
four locations that make up the
strategic petroleum reserve for purposes
of this release we will be releasing
from all four of those locations if you
look at the
actual operational capacity across all
four of them
it is actually up to four million
barrels a day in operational capacity so
actually executing a million barrels a
day is well within the operational
constraints
and a big part of that is because a lot
of that moves by pipeline and so they it
to established off-take points that's
point number one point number two
there's been some question about will
there be sufficient market interest or
sufficient uh demand including on the
transport side and i would say there
that
the most the best indicator is what just
happened in the market when in the last
uh the last sale that the the spr
tendered was two and a half times over
subscribed uh so certainly there is
significant demand in the market and
that you would expect because uh supply
is constrained uh and prices are high so
uh so we fully expect that the uh
strategic petroleum user will execute
against this per the president's
direction uh to your question about the
timing of the impact um
i've already seen and as we came in here
you know oil's trading down about six
percent uh today but the way that we
think about this is in terms of supply
and the market constraint and so the the
supply in the global market obviously
the price of oil set at the global at
the margin the global market
the global supply is down
because of russian oil
the million barrels a day plus what our
allies and partners uh are uh uh
intending to deliver and there's a there
is a meeting tomorrow morning of the
international energy agency in paris an
emergency meeting and i won't get ahead
of the specific commitments in that
context but as the president said we're
confident that our allies and partners
will
uh provide tens of millions of barrels
additional into the market so we're
looking at well in excess of a million
barrels a day of additional supply onto
the market for and
importantly
for several months
that that is the most
um ambitious aggressive historic effort
to try to replace supply in the short
term so certainly there is uncertainty
about pricing and and lots of different
factors
affect uh price across time but we
we are confident that this is about the
largest effort that
oil that
countries with oil reserves have ever
taken to supply the market in this way
good prices come down in a matter of
days or weeks i know it's difficult to
pinpoint but just for americans who
budget um based on how much they have to
spend on gasoline what should they be
bracing for
well the as the the president uh spoke
to today um that is uncertain and so you
know in being uh being very clear um the
the market price is impossible uh to
predict with certainty one thing that i
will say for sure is that as the price
of oil comes down it's incredibly
important that the uh that flows through
to the consumer in terms of the price of
gas as quickly as feasible we've seen
that be a problem uh in the past and is
definitely an issue that we are focused
on just
i think what you just said which is um
you've identified there's been a problem
between crude oil prices and what folks
are paying at the pump
and laid some of the blame for that at
oil companies in the past the president
today and his remarks
um spoke to some extent about how there
were good actors and bad actors uh
in terms of folks who are ramping up
production right now versus folks who
are sort of banking profit so i want to
give you an opportunity for americans
who want to do the patriotic thing
where should they be going to buy their
gas right now are there are there good
companies that have worked with the
administration and
folks that you're frustrated with right
now and then
my other question was on
your former friends kind of in the
green community that have expressed i
think
some level of frustration with the
announcement today feeling like it's
doubling down on
fossil fuels
obviously i know you've kind of made
this argument that long term you're
trying to pivot towards green energy
especially with the second part of the
announcement today
uh but what do you say to climate
activists who are sort of frustrated
right now
great so on the first on the first part
of the question i would say our goal is
to provide relief
to all americans in all geographies
across the country and that means doing
everything we can to bring down the
price of gas at the pump everywhere
and
so
that's our uh that's our uh focus and
the issue of the prices uh of gas going
up very quickly and tracking oil prices
and coming down uh much more slowly is
not new um it's old enough that
economists have a particular term
associated with it called rockets and
feathers but it just because we can
identify it doesn't mean that it is um
it's
uh it reflects an efficient market or
competitive market so that that has been
that has been our focus
on your your second question i i want to
be really clear and i think the
president you know the president said
this better uh today but i would just
underscore it
the circumstances uh in global oil
markets today and global energy markets
today provide the clearest possible
signal why the united states needs to do
everything it can to accelerate toward
energy security and true energy
independence and the only way that we
can ultimately do that
is to reduce and eliminate our
dependence on
on fossil fuels that's what the
president was clear about today and that
in fact in the very near term
making sure that we have adequate supply
is critically important for american
families who are suffering
but the opportunity to actually work in
partnership with our european allies for
example to help them
reduce their own dependence by reducing
demand for
fossil energy by
moving forward on the plan that the
president underscored today we have a
historic opportunity to do that and we
are wasting no time and we are taking no
this is not causing us to do anything
but but move even more quickly in the
steps that we we can take i think the
message that we have is that not only
not only can we uh do these things
together but we have to do these things
together
uh thank you i just wanted to follow up
about the uh allies and partners who
would be participating can you give any
additional detail will china be
participating in the oil release
so i don't want to get ahead of
any specific
commitments but i'll say a couple of
things the first is that as with every
action that we have taken
in relation to the war in ukraine
the president and our entire team have
been consulting and working incredibly
closely with allies and partners on this
this was a significant topic in the
president's call with the quint on
monday at the leader level our teams
have been working around the clock
together before going into that and in
the period since
the
iea
is uh the body of
countries that have significant stocks
and reserves and
the
formal process that they under that they
go in to and the united states is a is a
member of the iea is to
bring forward a proposal for a
collective release and the quit the
decision is whether there is a
collective release and then
uh how much each country will uh
contribute into that so that's the
process that will
that will happen starting tomorrow
morning i don't want to get ahead of it
the only thing that i would say and i
think this is probably implicit in what
we what we have done here
is
we the united states and the president
made an explicit decision that the
united states would lead here and lead
with a historic use of our reserves we
have those reserves we have the
capability to do that and so uh that was
a that was an explicit decision at the
same time looking to partner with allies
and i think we all see that um reflected
over the course of the next couple of
days ea members are the only ones
participating in the release is that
accurate well what i can tell you is
that the iea
the the meeting tomorrow will be of iea
minor
of iea members uh and that will be the
question will be
uh about a collective release in that
context we continue to engage with
non-iea members china and other
countries around uh their uh reserves
and will continue to do so but the
immediate uh the immediate step at hand
will be the iea
gas might drop between 10 and 35 cents a
gallon brian does that sound about right
to you 10 and 35 cents a gallon does
that sound about right that's the
president
the president had discussions with
leaders in the oil industry ahead of
this announcement what if any assurances
were given about increasing production
were there any guarantees made
so what what uh what uh what what we
have engaged with oil companies uh and
energy companies on they have been
public about so
you can see the reason why the market
expectation has now increased to an
expectation of about a million barrels a
day of additional production online is
because many of those companies have
i've gone out and been quite explicit
about their intention to ramp up uh
production across time and that's an
outgrowth of the of a number of the
conversations uh that we have had and so
the user lose it approach is
is is consistent in the sense that those
companies that are looking to ramp
production or to bring back online
shuttered wells
those permitted areas would would
obviously be unaffected
as i said it's on it's uncertain and so
i'll let the process
what are the conversations with indy
another country that's dealing with uh
major oil issues gasoline issues and
also what are the guarantees
with this one million a day for six
months for americans
so our there our conversations with all
countries that have
uh reserves
is um similar in encouraging them to
participate and to
contribute in consistent with their
stocks their available stocks and their
and their circumstances we have seen to
date um a quite extraordinary
willingness to participate including iea
and non-iea members to participate in
those coordinated releases including the
indian government to date and so the
work of diplomacy and engagement with
our allies and partners is aimed to
to make sure that that that continues
more about
the united states china and india when
you are looking at these beaten
three top three uh consumers of oil
so
what when we're talking about collective
releases the issue is actually where are
the country who are the countries that
actually have the largest reserves not
the largest consumers but the largest
reserves so those are the the iea
though
certainly but in terms of releasing
supply onto the market that's a function
of the reserves what are the guarantees
for the american consumer in these six
months in the midst of covet in the
midst of this war in the midst of russia
doing whatever it's doing well and i
think this goes to the question the
gentleman's question as well what the
president what the president has said is
that is in terms of guarantee is he's
going to do everything that he can he's
going to stay at this even in a very
uncertain period uh to do everything
within his power to try to provide
relief to families and we can now commit
that we will deliver
a million barrels a day into the into
the market consistent with the
president's uh directive across time
for one more
um thanks brian um
talking about countries that may or may
not get involved curious if there's been
any more conversation with
venezuela iran saudi arabia
about boosting production or about
working out how we can
potentially see more of their oil get
back on the market and then on the use
or lose it proposal he talked about the
idea that companies would be fined if
they don't use
their leases is there existing
legislation he's referring to or how
would that work
and how is that
if not
legal how is that in keeping with sort
of the
capitalistic uh he says he's a
capitalist of course who is the
government to be telling businesses what
to do with something they've leased i
guess sure so uh on your first uh there
are conversations gaming is ongoing but
i don't have any i don't have any uh new
update on that front on the on the
second
the the
we start from the premise that all of
these are leases on public land so it's
federal uh it's federal land and so it's
a pup your your assets as a uh
as citizens and as taxpayers and so the
way the process works is that companies
lease tracks of land they then we're in
areas where they are more interested in
potentially discovering they then seek a
permit within their leased areas
and so the way that this policy would
operate would be to say going forward in
those areas where you are holding leased
land but you are not exploring
then you
then you would pay
incrementally on that i would say two
things one is when companies lease the
lease with the federal government again
this is companies operating with the
federal government on public land the
lease is to
explore and to pursue
uh production the the that's that's the
stated that those are the stated these
terms so it is it's appropriate
how to increase more supply
and so
in those areas where we already know
that the leases have occurred the
permits have occurred there's nothing
more that needs to happen we should be
encouraging companies to operate and if
they don't intend to or they don't they
don't they don't want to then they could
hand those leases back to the government
are you still concerned that gas prices
could hit record highs this spring and
this summer
so i the i i'm not i'm not going to
predict uh where the uh where the market
will go uh you'll you'll find me uh not
predicting on any particular uh forward
um
uh forward data point what i will say is
that because of the president's actions
today because of a historic effort to
put a million barrels a day of supply
into the market and because of the
effort to work with allies and partners
and galvanize the global response on
this front the market will be
significantly more well supplied and
prices will be lower than if we didn't
take this historic action and that's you
know that's what our focus is actions
that we can take to make sure that um
the that prices come down as much as we
can
one on three security real quick do you
have any updates on the president's
efforts to prevent real food shortages
sparked by the war
so we're uh it's a
issue of a top focus and we will have
more to say uh on that issue in the
coming days but i don't have a specific
announcement for you today
only incrementally raising production
i think it's the same answer as the the
question earlier we're continuing to
have those conversations but i don't
have anything new
right now at the public
in the ua you have a president who you
have a president who's doing everything
that he possibly can to try to address
that situation including i would say the
president announced today and i would
encourage you all to uh to uh to really
cover it and look into it 3.2 million
dollars through the weatherization
program that goes directly to low-income
families low-income family can get a 6
500 grant to make their home more energy
efficient bring down their energy costs
by hundreds of dollars a year and
improve the health of their home that's
something the president did this week
putting that money out in addition to
the other issues that we discussed today
thanks
thank you all very much
so if you will
just indulge me for a minute i have a
few announcements i'd like to make at
the top here so just bear with me um so
today we're marking transgender the
transgender day of visibility by
celebrating transgender americans who
are thriving and making their
communities stronger unfortunately
transgender americans particularly
children continue to face unacceptably
high levels of bullying and
discrimination as you know the president
signed one of the most comprehensive
executive orders on lgbtqi plus rights
in history shortly after taking office
and this administration has repeatedly
and forcefully called out state
legislatures that are advancing
legislation that discriminates against
trans children and their families today
the state department and department of
homeland security announced new steps
that will improve the travel experience
for transgender americans and the
department of health and human services
has released new resources for
transgender kids and their families to
help protect their mental health and
ensure they receive the care they need
to thrive
finally the president is reiterating his
call for the senate to pass the equality
act to provide long overdue civil rights
protections to transgender and lgbtqi
plus americans
as the president told transgender
americans in his state of the union
address this administration will always
have your back so you can be yourself
and reach your god-given potential
today we're also celebrating the life
and legacy of cesar estrada chavez a
champion for social justice an advocate
for farm workers and working people who
build and sustain our nation
a leader who has inspired generations of
people to fight organize and expand
opportunities for workers
when president biden became president he
placed a bust of cesar chavez in the
oval office as a reminder of the values
and his vision to fight for respect
social justice and equal dignity for all
workers
the biden harris administration remains
committed to building an economy from
the bottom up and the middle out that
works for all we fought hard to pass the
american rescue plan that helped latino
workers families and small businesses to
ensure that they had the support they
needed through the pandemic and we
created a historic task force on worker
organizing and empowerment to help
workers to organize to provide an earned
pathway to citizenship
today we join people across the country
celebrating and honoring cesar chavez's
legacy while we continue to advance the
rights and dignity of working people
today new cdc data further underscored
the mental health impact of the pandemic
including the fact that nearly half of
high schoolers reported that they felt
persistently sad or hopeless during the
past year as a mother of young kids i
know this is a huge concern for so many
parents
the president has been acutely aware of
the mental health impact of the pandemic
on young people which is why he made it
a day one priority to get schools
reopened safely and secure much needed
resources through the american rescue
plan to address youth mental health a
bill which every single republican i
would note voted against
we've invested and a half billion
dollars in programs that support mental
health and well-being including tens of
millions for programs that specifically
address youth mental health for instance
schools across the country are using
american rescue plan funds to hire
school counselors and social workers to
address this crisis
according to this new cdc data the very
kind of connection that helps protect
youth mental health
president biden remains deeply focused
on this very real crisis and providing
the resources to address it as part of
the unity agenda that he laid out during
the state of the union address and his
budget
president put forward a historic
increase in funding to strengthen and
expand youth mental health services and
we're going to continue to build on this
progress and do everything we can to
support the mental health and well-being
of our young people
and then lastly but certainly not least
today we announced additional sanctions
on russian technology companies that
enable putin's war of choice we will
prevent them from procuring western
technology and evading our severe
sanctions
we're also expanding our sanctions
authority to target additional sectors
of the russian economy important to
putin including aerospace maritime and
the electronic sectors
in the coming days the commerce
department will also take further action
to degrade russia's defense aerospace
and maritime sectors by adding 120
entities in russia and belarus to the
entity list bringing the number of
russian and belarusian parties added to
the list over 200 since the invasion
began
being added to this list means that
these entities can no longer get us
cutting edge technology without a
license which will which will in most if
not all of these cases be denied
compared to the same time period last
year u.s exports to russia of items
subject to our new export controls have
decreased by 99 percent
by value
the power of these restrictions will
compound over time as russia draws down
any remaining stockpiles for example
spare parts for certain planes and tanks
we will continue to impose unprecedented
costs strengthen ukraine's hand and make
putin's war of choice a strategic
failure
so thanks for hanging with me i told you
had a lot and i'm happy to say questions
darling thanks kate a couple on russia
can you elaborate first on the
president's comment a while ago that
there are some indication that putin has
either
fired some of his uh top officials or
put some of them under house arrest what
what evidence or information does the
white house have well uh the president's
words on that speak for them for
themselves i don't have a lot to add by
the way of detail what i would point to
is certainly information that we made
public yesterday
about
putin and his military um you know i
think writ large we have seen that this
invasion has been a strategic failure uh
for putin and for russia they are uh
working to redefine uh the intentional
the the um
initial i should say the initial aims uh
of their invasion uh and when we've seen
time and again that the sanctions that
have been applied uh are providing uh
are exacting extreme costs on their
economy so
i don't have anything to add to what the
president said except to say uh we have
seen uh incontrovertible evidence that
this has been a strategic disaster for
russia and the second question is the
united states and the uk have been
working together to release intelligence
information since before
russia invaded ukraine i was wondering
if you could talk a little bit about the
value of that relationship and how the
white house thinks it's affected putin's
conduct in the war releasing
releasing that kind of information
well i can't speak to how it's impacted
putin's conduct that's again as i said
yesterday i'm not a spokesperson for the
kremlin uh what i can say though is that
we've made every effort to be
transparent even from the time before
putin invaded we worked to make sure
that we were providing
information that
gave a sense of what we knew russia was
going to do um i think it you know to
call them out in that way and to be
clear uh that we knew what their
intentions were um uh had the impact of
putting them on their back foot i ca
again i can't speak to how that's
impacted their calculus that's for them
to say um but i think we've seen writ
large that the the invasion has been a
strategic error is leaving russia weaker
putin himself has said that the
sanctions have
imposed unprecedented costs on the
russian economy and our role in this uh
our role is to continue to strengthen
ukraine on the battlefield as we've been
doing with an unprecedented amount of
security assistance and to continue to
strengthen their hand at the negotiating
table just one more quickly but going
back to the information that you
mentioned you all released yesterday
is that some sort of an attempt to um
so division among the russian leadership
and if so does the white house think
that is working it is simply an effort
to continue to paint the picture of what
a strategic blunder this decision has
been uh for vladimir putin
on that it seems you're releasing even
more information today a u.s official
says you have information that indicates
that some russian government senior
officials likely disagreed with putin's
decision to invade ukraine that their
disillusionment is probably amplified by
russia's military under performance is
it your understanding that putin is
losing the support of some of his top
officials and why release this as well
well again i don't have anything further
to add to the specifics there i can only
speak to
what this underscores which is the
larger sense that this has been a
failure for russia uh you know i think
we've seen reporting uh that morale
amongst the russian military is low and
i think
that would not come as a surprise to
anyone who's seen uh what the russian
military is uh is enduring here you have
conscripts you have people who've been
brought in to fight this incredibly
grueling battle so i don't think it's a
surprise to anybody um that morale is
low but beyond that i i don't have
anything specific that i can add like
all of the president's comments about
you know people being put under under
house arrest or arrested can you say is
it your understanding that those who are
being arrested under house arrest are
ones who sort of broke the bad news to
the president about the military's
performance or are they ones who now are
disagreeing with um
uh disagree with with the decision to
invade in the first place i i don't have
any further additional detail that i can
add like you keep saying though that you
know this is to try and uh you know
paint a picture of putin's strategic
blunder or strategic error but it
certainly seems like you're
needling and trolling vladimir putin
here those are your words not ours i we
have been very clear that we are uh
everything that we are doing here is
designed to advance uh our ultimate
strategic aim which is strengthening as
i said strengthening ukraine on the
battlefield strengthening their hand at
the negotiating table giving them what
they need to push back on russian
aggression and i think it is
self-evident based on uh what we've seen
since putin invaded on february 24th as
we've seen their economy collapse we've
seen the ruble collapse uh you know the
the impact of his choice uh has been
significant and we're going to continue
to advance our strategy of doing
everything we can to ensure that uh
ukraine uh is uh has what they need to
continue to push back on russian
aggression
this may be a little late late-breaking
i don't know but there have been reports
uh in the last hour or so about um
concerns at chernobyl with russian uh
with russians leaving the nuclear plant
because of some kind of exposure do you
have any um does the us government have
any information about what might be
going on there and whether uh sort of
how broad the danger is there i have not
seen that since we came into this room
but i'm happy to go look into it and we
can come back to you with
answers hey on uh uncovered i wonder if
you can comment on reports that there's
an agreement in principle for 10 billion
dollars in additional covert aid i think
senator ron we talked about it earlier
today
so as we talked about yesterday uh we
are obviously very hopeful that congress
is making progress uh as we need to get
this urgent funding that we need to
fight covet 19. the president has been
very clear there is an a strong sense of
urgency here
you know you heard him say yesterday
that congress's failure to act is
already having severe consequences
including on our supply of monoclonal
antibodies and treatments for the immuno
compromised so these are as you note
ongoing active negotiations on this and
so we're certainly not going to
negotiate from the podium but i will say
that the president has been very clear
that uh there's an urgent need for this
funding and we're very hopeful that
congress is going to come to a solution
on this
one follow on that i don't think the
plan calls for slashing some of the
foreign aid um you know fighting has
said repeatedly that we can't just you
know take care of ourselves that we have
to you know the the pandemic isn't going
to stop there's not no wall we can build
would he sign a bill or would he veto a
bill that doesn't include significant
foreign aid well what i would say to
this is uh we have been very clear and
the president has been very clear both
publicly and in private
about the acute need for funding of our
global response for weeks if not months
and in the past day our position has
been very clear about the importance
here right now countries in fact are
declining our doses because they don't
have the infrastructure in place to take
our life-saving vaccines funding will
obviously help solve this issue and i
actually want to read to you a letter to
the president signed by 14 u.s senators
half of whom are republicans quote we
urge you in the strongest possible terms
to do more to lead global efforts to end
this pandemic and increase global
vaccine access so we hope that these
senators will follow their own advice
and provide resources for the global
response because now is the time to act
and we're not going to be able to put
this pandemic behind us until we stop
the spread and proliferation of new
variants globally so the president has
been very clear he believes this funding
is important but again we're going to
let congress work through and we're very
hopeful that they are going to come to a
solution
thanks kate i want to ask you again
about the president's comments today
when he was asked about the information
that putin is being left in the dark by
his advisors he seemed much less
confident in the intelligence than you
were from the podium and other top
officials here when he was asked about
it today he said it's an open question
there's a lot of speculation um he seems
to be self-isolating he said but we
don't have hard evidence you said from
the podium we have information that
putin felt misled by the russian
military why the disconnect i don't see
a disconnect there we were clear
yesterday that we shared a piece of
information that helps paint a picture
about how this has been a strategic
failure for russia the president said
there's a lot of speculation he didn't
say we have hard evidence we're
confident and there's there is plenty of
discussion and that's part of what we
did yesterday was put additional
information into the public sphere into
the conversation i don't think there's a
disconnect between those two things the
president was making statement about
about
where uh things currently stand where he
understands things to currently stand i
don't think that's um i don't think
that's in any way uh at odds with what
we said yesterday is the administration
confident that putin is being left in
the dark by his top advisors you stand
by everything
we put forward information yesterday i i
think you can draw the appropriate
conclusion from that uh we would not put
it forward if we didn't have confidence
in it one more on hunter biden who has
been uh in the headlines again recently
during the last presidential debate
then vice president was asked if there
was anything inappropriate or unethical
about his son's relationships business
dealings in china and or ukraine
the president said nothing was unethical
he went on to say my son has not made
money in terms of this thing about what
you're talking about china does the
white house stand by that comment that
the vice president made we absolutely
stand by the president's comment and i
would point you to
the reporting on this which reference
statements that we made at the time that
we gave to the washington post who
worked on this story uh and but as you
know i don't speak for hunter biden so
there's not more i can say on that
thank you kate um on releasing barrels
from the strategic reserve
this move does not resolve the
structural deficit that we have in the
last two times the administration
released barrels of oil it didn't have a
measurable impact on gas prices so what
makes this administration believe that
this move is going to have an impact
this time
this is as you heard brian say this is a
historic and unprecedented
release in terms of size it is going to
help meet the mismatch between supply
and demand in the market a million
barrels a day is a significant
addition to the marketplace and is going
to as i say is going to address the some
of the mismatch between
supply and demand and i think what
americans should take away from this
announcement today is that president
biden is relentlessly focused on doing
everything he can to ensure that putin's
price hike does not hit them at the gas
pump so what they've seen from him i
think since the day he took office is a
focus on uh doing what he can to address
kitchen table issues to address the
things that people across the country
are worried about
including gas prices and so today
you know not only is it historic in
scope but it as you heard brian talk
about this has also been
the president has led a global effort to
galvanize response to this
because he knows that
rising prices at the pump hurt families
and he's doing everything in his power
to bring those prices down
this is going to bring up the supply in
the short term but it's not you know a
long term solution and you know one
analyst has said that
if the market maintains a structural
deficit for a long period of time
releasing reserves might actually keep
prices higher so if this does not work
in the way that you think it's going to
work will the administration stop
releasing a million barrels a day
we will certain well i won't i won't
speak to uh what we might do in the
hypothetical depending on uh where the
market goes what i will say broadly is
of course uh we would always adjust our
strategy to do uh what is most effective
to bring prices down what i would say
about the long term to your to your
question about the long term is you know
and i think you heard brian articulate
this really well and of course the
president spoke to it very powerfully
today too which is this ultimately uh
shows that dependence on fossil fuels
dependence on foreign oil is not
is not in the sustainable long-term best
interest of the united states and that's
why
the president has put forward a really
aggressive plan
to move us to clean energy
sources of uh
of energy that we can make here in the
united states that's part of as you
heard brian talk about the defense
production act announcement that he made
today to help us make electric vehicle
batteries in the united states uh you
know the president feels very strongly
um that we need to move we need to make
significant strides toward a clean
energy economy it's something he's been
very focused on you'll remember for
those of you who covered the campaign
it's something he ran on uh and so he's
very focused on ensuring that we're
taking those strides because that is
that is actually the long-term solution
here
sanctions the russian google has
almost returned to its pre-war levels so
does the administration believe that the
sanctions are still working
uh absolutely uh yes and what i would
say about uh what i would say about the
ruble is
what we're seeing here is an artificial
propping up of the ruble by the russian
central bank uh and by uh and and by the
russian government
there are
avenues are closed off to allow
the sale of rubles they are basically
taking artificial measures um uh to keep
the ruble propped up i would also say
that in the first uh you know in the
first few days in the first i would say
also in the first few days uh after the
conflict began
uh the ruble was a reliable measure of
where the russian economy is uh but it
is not any longer in part because of
these artificial steps that are being
taken so if you look at things like
dramatic inflation in russia you look at
private investment pulling out of russia
if you look at putin himself saying that
the sanctions have uh imposed
unprecedented costs i think that's a
better metric of where the russian
economy is right now steve i want to
follow up on kristin's question about
the president's son
is it your understanding it's the
president's view that as he looks at all
of hunter biden's business dealings with
his uncle
that
neither hunter biden or james biden
committed any crimes or did anything
that was unlawful
so
i don't have anything further to add
from this podium we addressed this uh
with the washington post we pointed to
statements uh that were made in the fall
of 2020 when we address these questions
and i don't have anything additional to
add from this podium can i ask you if
there have been if you're aware if there
have been any discussions here inside
this white house about whether the
president might use his pardon or
commutation power with respect to either
his son or his brother that's not a
hypothetical i'm going to entertain i
don't have anything to add from this
podium justin thanks um
the president met with progressive
lawmakers uh last time here at the white
house and afterwards they
said that they pressed him on sort of a
laundry list of executive orders and
actions that they'd like him to take
cancelling student debt raising the
overtime threshold um prescription drug
costs
are any of those sort of
uh
live here in the white house right now
are they under consideration especially
i think relative to this negotiation
that's going on um about
elements of buildback better and whether
you know pushing both of those executive
actions might
help or hurt that
well i don't have any specific
announcements on any of those specific
pieces what i would say more broadly is
that from day one the president has used
the full array of tools at his disposal
to achieve his objectives and that's
included legislative action regulatory
action and executive orders and he will
certainly continue to do so but i don't
have any specific uh coming actions to
preview for you right now
sorry real quick jordan asked yesterday
about the uh meeting
in india with senior administration
officials wondering now that those
wrapped up um do you have any newfound
confidence that india will
decide against maintaining oil trade
with russia or a sense of you know what
came out of the
so i don't have any specific i knew you
were going to ask this and i need to
follow up with specifics because i don't
have any i don't have any additional
specifics to read out beyond the fact
that they were productive conversations
um
you know delep singh the deputy national
security advisor for international
economics had really good uh discussions
with his counterparts um and uh and i
know that the conversation was
productive i don't have additional
specifics to read out but i will and by
the way i should be clear i meant
generically i know you will ask not you
specifically
three thanks kate um so on the svr some
republicans uh for example senator
cassidy have said that the president
with his uh move today uh in terms of
the unprecedented uh drawdown of the
spr that he's risking long-term energy
security um to salvage coal members is
that something that has um played into
the white house's calculus at all um and
how would you respond to respond to that
absolutely not what the president is
doing is using every tool available to
him to bring prices down for the
american people at the pump
he's been clear that his focus is
working to relieve the pain and the
burden
that working families middle class
families are feeling as a result of
price hikes so every policy decision
that he makes is driven by
a desire to do everything he can to ease
that burden on on working families
just uh two quick uh
quick ones following up on kristin's
line of inquiry as well
i know hunter biden is not a government
employee you don't speak for him has the
president read these reports
do you guys take them to him when the
inquiry's come in and what has been his
reaction
i don't have anything additional to add
on this from the podium but thank you
caitlyn and on title 42 you're preparing
to
end this policy at some point soon here
um there has been some concern expressed
by democrats
as well as republicans the democrats
notably about how the administration's
preparing to wind that down and prepare
for
the surge i believe some administration
officials say they're
anticipating a record surge
what is the administration doing
to not only alleviate those concerns
from moderate democrats some of whom may
face voter ire for that uh but then more
broadly how is you know the
administration preparing
for that surge if you can sort of
generally summarize it well
so thank you for the question uh first i
would note as i said yesterday and we
have said many many times obviously this
is a decision that the cdc will make
that said of course we are preparing for
contingencies um and so what i would say
is uh you know our goal is going to be
to process migrants in a safe and
orderly manner but also
to be clear most individuals who cross
the border without legal authorization
will be promptly placed into removal
proceedings and if they are unable to
establish a legal basis to remain in the
united states they'll be expeditiously
removed and returned to their country of
origin
as a reminder economic need and flight
from generalized violence is not a basis
for asylum but rather asylum is for
those with a well-founded fear of
persecution on a protected ground and so
asylum and other legal migration
pathways should remain available to
those seeking protection and we're
working to expand legal pathways in the
region so that people don't make this
treacherous journey obviously trying to
enter the united states illegally
carries consequences and no one should
try to make this dangerous journey or
try to unlawfully enter the united
states
the department of homeland security as i
noted yesterday
put together a preparedness plan to
address the number of people coming to
our border
and work with our partners in the region
to provide safe options for people
outside the united states we are
obviously working to deliver a more
efficient and fair processing system
through for example a dedicated docket
to conduct speedier and fair immigration
proceedings for families who arrive
between ports of entry so there is a
significant amount of work we obviously
inherited when we came into this
administration we inherited an
immigration system that had been
systematically uh dismantled by the
previous administration there's been a
tremendous amount of work from day one
uh to rebuild that uh and we are
certainly focused on uh continuing to
assert order at the border
one point of clarification when the
president says he believes putin is
firing or putting senior advisors on
house arrest he's talking about military
advisors right
no i have nothing additional i can add
beyond the president's comments on this
you can't say that he's referencing the
russian
foreign minister i think his words speak
for him speak for themselves
sorry i've got one more um president
biden has not spoken to president putin
in quite some time are there any plans
being made for the two of them to speak
not currently we've been very clear that
any in any re-engagement of diplomacy at
that level would require significant uh
demonstration from the russians of
serious de-escalation and we have not
seen that oh you need to see
de-escalation before he'll speak to
president putin again we've been very
clear about that
white house was previously considered a
gas tax holiday but basically kind of
ruled against it i'm curious if this is
still off the table uh and what does the
white house think about individual
states that are considering or have
already enacted their own gas tax
holidays so i it is it is not off the
table in fact uh the president is
looking at every option
to provide relief to consumers
around
around gas prices
obviously a lot of these conversations
are happening in congress
but again the president is not taking
anything off the table at this stage
does the us stand with them in rejecting
that as well uh we do and uh the german
chancellor i think has been very clear
that that the contracts exist as they
exist and there's going to be no change
there
my question is a question your colleague
that who cannot be here my question is
uh
again on allies and partners in the oil
reserves the president referred to 30 to
50 million barrels
brian didn't want to name any countries
but where did he get this number and
canada being the main exporter of oil to
the u.s is it the has the country been
solicited
well i can't speak to specific uh
bilateral engagements but i would note
that obviously the president discussed
this uh the g7 uh when he was in europe
last week this is a continuing ongoing
conversation with our allies and
partners it is a key priority
maintaining stability in our energy
markets so um yeah you know those
conversations are ongoing and we
obviously consult very closely with our
allies and partners
sorry from the colleagues sorry from the
colleague who cannot be here it's about
the prime minister of pakistan accused
the us of uh
working with your position to remove him
from power you just said that today
what's the white house reaction there is
absolutely no truth to that allegation
to go back to the covet deal i know
you're not going to negotiate from the
podium and the president has obviously
warned about the severe consequences if
there is no funding but if there is a 10
billion deal which some of the top
negotiators say they're getting close to
what would the administration then be
able to cover that long list the
president went through yesterday
everything that stops over the coming
months what is saved over the coming
months and what is still done at risk
well obviously the specifics of this
deal are continuing to be worked out so
i don't have a breakdown for you of
exactly where that funding would go this
is a live negotiation and again
obviously we're not going to negotiate
from here except to say broadly that
this is incredibly an incredibly urgent
need uh and we really hope that the
congress is is coming to a solution on
this top priority that you say that is
the mustang we have to fund over the
next couple of months i'm not going to
lay that out as the negotiation is
happening obviously this is being worked
through on capitol hill um and uh we're
hopeful that they're going to come to a
solution soon
yeah kate i wanted to ask about the use
of the user policy that the president
has today uh it requires uh
congressional approval uh and o'brien
was briefly asked about this but i just
wanted to clarify i mean has the white
house prepare the legislation on this
uh does it have support lined up in
congress and what is the timeline you're
hoping to pass this measure and is that
it really even realistic uh in an evenly
divided senate right now with uh
midterms coming up in the fall
well uh you know the proposal would
actually build on uh the version that's
uh in the house bill so there's a
version of this that is already yep
there's a version of this that's already
been put forward
obviously the president looks forward to
working with congress on it he believes
uh it's a critically important piece of
helping to move our
energy dependence from overseas back
home and and to move us toward a clean
energy economy so we intend to work very
closely with congress uh this will be a
priority for the president um but in
terms of a specific timeline i i don't
have any for anything further on that
with the house bill or you say you're
building on that what does that look
like that will be an ongoing negotiation
we will continue to build on it that's a
discussion that we'll have with congress
obviously uh this announcement just came
today so uh that work will be ongoing
thank you all very much appreciate it
okay do you take any responsibility in
the president by the approval numbers